there is no one road that connects
dreams to reality there's no bridge that
attaches the world around you to the
unknown there's no way of ever knowing
that the chips will fall in your favor
what you do have
is the ability to believe a chance to
turn everything you are into something
incredible to trust that with dedication
and persistence you will find your way
it's when everything stacks up against
you when the odds tell you no that
belief will quiet the noise
believing was never about the way things
are it's about what they can be it's not
about having the most talent it's about
turning that talent you have into
results day by day the most beautiful
thing about the world we live in is the
opportunity where every step you take
can point you in the direction of
something amazing where every breath of
air you take in can become the beginning
of something new something that will
change our world forever to believe is
to give yourself the keys to a kingdom
to create the best version of yourself
to go where others won't because in this
short life we lead there are two options
to live to dream to explore or to
quietly wish that we did
and I'll tell you the difference between
the Steve Jobs the Michael Jordan's the
Elon Musk's of this world and everyone
else is that they believed they had
something special and they passionately
followed those beliefs that is the
formula you are far less likely to worry
about what waits around the corner if
you have faith in your ability to rise
regardless to know that life can throw
any obstacle at you and you will
overcome you will always find a way to
overcome that is what you do don't waste
time with the thoughts that don't propel
you to greatness in a world that so
desperately wants you to stay where you
are rise rise above it the best things
this world has to offer belong to those
who value themselves enough to take it